this is a production of Cornell
University
marble Crips going to be here through
the introduction today otherwise
occupied you have been out to do all the
staff and thorough here is my pleasure
this morning to are going to step two of
the prenup tools where Travis blood and
his team are going through the process
of finding out about us as finding out
whom and this group as a pre mood to I
hope joining the department for culture
so I asked Travis to the little bit of
background about the process because I
know the faculty that would that would
he be were very aware or are aware will
strike on but maybe the students in the
audience might be adjusted spectacle of
minutes but other than that but positive
Travis and look forward to hearing your
learning opportunities for
that's good thanks good good afternoon
forgot it was morning I didn't I could
get one dose of princes today though I
came from about an hour and a half long
in formal formal ish research session
with his his daughter who's a high
school student in the TST new visions AG
and life sciences program a natural
resources burger and she I'm helping her
with a bit of a research project
fortuitous at this stage of my career
dr. up so I got to visit my they
Christmas morning but just to give a
little context the last Tuesday in
October the college decided or announced
that they would be closing the
Department of Education here at Cornell
and so the faculty are being reassigned
to other units throughout the college
and has been a very individualistic
process early on we visited a couple of
us in agricultural education visited
with a couple of faculty here in
horticulture and explored some
opportunities and those awkward those
conversations snow balled into more
serious conversations about maybe the AG
ed part of what we did in the Department
of Education to contribute to the
faculty here in the Horticulture
Department and so we're in this this
process it's been as I said an
individualized process for all the
faculty and our department depending on
which department they go to Marvin early
on back in January and said that
we wanted to join horticulture by the
best thing that I can do is for my wife
I to host an entire faculty grad student
undergrad student dinner at our house so
I asked for him to select a couple of
days that I haven't heard anything back
but anyway that's where r at so we're
checking out horticulture we've looked
at a couple of different departments in
and hopefully we have in Ag education
collaborations with lots of faculty and
different units throughout the
university about to see hopefully some
reasons why was that horticulture might
be a good fit certainly at this time so
we'll start with with leveraging
opportunity just a bit of who we are
because it was you've got a whole
entourage here and I don't know that
it's my team just the way the university
of structure they sort of have to follow
where i go for a little bit but jeff
perry is a newly hired lecture in
agricultural education some of you may
have known bill camp who was a professor
in Ag education for about six years here
at cornell he retired actually his third
retirement in life of his front paw
reality was a army colonel and retired
from Virginia Tech and then retired from
Cornell so he's living in Hilton Head
South Carolina Jeff's here with us now
Heather Davis's nag literacy specialist
works with the new york AG in the
classroom program sherry light ball is
teacher professional development
specialist works with about 250
agriculture teachers throughout the
state julia talansky is a youth
development specialist working with the
new york state FFA association which is
slightly under 4,000
throughout the state and then we should
have a graduate teaching assistant come
on board perhaps in the fall or next to
you just a little bit about my
background I'm currently an assistant
professor until friday and so that's I
think or license I don't know when I
could save successfully navigated
promotion and tenure but when the
universe of integrations enough that on
friday hopefully that becomes effective
I grew up in Indiana tant attended
Purdue University majoring in
agricultural education for a bachelor's
degree in a master's degree I taught
five and a half years at a small rural
high school in northwestern Indiana and
then it's ended the University of
Florida who work on PhD and in high
school there some of the courses i
taught horticulture at communications
leadership and act business class we
teach in a if you're not familiar with
school-based agricultural education in
high schools and middle schools
throughout the country and approximately
7,500 of those agriculture courses are
taught they mirror at a more basic level
kind of the courses that are taught here
at the university so he teach those kind
of introductory courses to our students
and then currently my wife and I and
we've got three daughters age 52 about
15 months are actively involved out in
the dragon community is anyone else in
drag night yeah Tony Helia from just to
give a bit of a background this is going
to be kind of a get-to-know-you us
presentation and then kind of see what
we're thinking about horticulture and
had an opportunity for some dialogue and
discussion at the end the research I've
conducted the spark Cornell has been
married classroom-based instructional
methodology had one large grant that
will be going next year into its fifth
year with the National
Center from Career and Technical
Education agricultural education from
the federal government policy standpoint
is a part of Career and Technical
Education and so we we've done some
research with literacy how students read
writer can be engaged in reading writing
more effectively in the classroom and so
very classroom-based we had an
experimental design in two states north
carolina or assuming South Carolina in
New York to examine the impact of
literacy strategies in career and
technical education so we train teachers
on a package of literacy strategies had
those teachers implement them and their
classroom on your long and measure the
impact on student achievement
unfortunately the results were positive
and for this next year we'll be rolling
out professional development it
throughout Oregon the whole state we
should be working with the miami-dade
School District the arlington virginia
school district and we'll be back in
Detroit at the Detroit Public Schools so
though to my knowledge the connects
between any of these things and what you
do in horticulture having been in
Detroit there's lots of land available
for urban agriculture so my last visit
there and talking with the we work but
the director of career technical
education and I had a side conversation
about agriculture programs urban AG
programs in the city of Detroit I mean
who's visited Detroit Reese make it yet
is it went from there there are a lot of
open space and it's a hotbed I think
in our apartment there's going to be
more more yeah they lost twenty five
percent population blessings as I may
see when you were if part of your urban
agriculture you're also doing because
some of the stuff include any landscape
horticulture Travis like you know the
guys at the turf back with the admission
state have been active is working on
sort of greeting it but not for food
production because some of that soil
isn't actually sunny thing you want to
grow it right so but but you know far as
you know may a soccer field or as any of
your work touched on things other than
in food production my work has really
been on this real classroom based
learning kinds of stuff that's not why I
decided to get a PhD in agricultural
education I love working with youth in
and about agriculture and but I'm also
realized an option for me real
opportunity here was a grant related to
what might be that dissertation was in
and I have a passion for reading and
teaching method so I went this way where
I'm going down to the future is more
geared towards agriculture and perhaps
you know we're going to have kinds of
things there's several ideas that are
floating about but in a way it's
fortuitous that our partners closed down
now because at the end of the promotion
and tenure process the end of this grant
I get a chance to refocus a little bit
and my passion is more tied to
agriculture or filter some so fast and
so nothing in the past but in the future
possible just to give you a brief
overview of some other smaller projects
that I've worked on over the last
several years I sent on the experiment
stations Committee on organization of
policy they have a Science and
Technology Committee that committee has
a social science and subcommittee that
directs the USDA on research rfas
how do we structure the language so that
there's some social science aspects to
those rfas and so as an outgrowth of
being serving with the Escott group they
have just completed a new science
roadmap for agricultural research and so
one of the first steps that was
conducted National Delphi study of
agricultural experts throughout the
country at land-grant universities all
the land grants throughout the nation so
we surveyed 240 key researchers to
identify research priorities again to
inform this science roadmap there's just
a glimpse of the 10 points of where the
universities were located that we found
researchers to survey here that the
Grand Challenge areas facing agriculture
that helped frame up this science
roadmap looking at developing renewable
energy and biofuel systems how do we
manage agricultural water usage how do
we mitigate and capitalise on either
maybe global climate change developing
plant products enhance safe and abundant
food supply belt similar to plants new
animal production practices and uses let
you read on rude jokes but what we try
to do this Delphi study is we asked each
experiment station director to nominate
their five best researchers at their
institution then we asked them what are
the broad challenges facing agriculture
and then even the smaller research
priority areas and so these were the
broader challenges that the folks
identified the researchers identified
for agriculture than within each of
these there were anywhere between
forward about
individual research priorities that then
we're used to develop the science
program so that's the way we contribute
more closely to agriculture this I found
just as interesting as our literacy work
also collaborate here with Michelle and
audio and Erica with a small farms
research or beginning farmer USDA grant
our goal on our end of the project is to
find ways to develop interest in
students in farming and agricultural
experiences and we also want to connect
local school-based agricultural
educators with local farmers and
communities either for field trips or
speaking well we took some students to
the NOFA conference back in January
trying to find ways to bridge that gap
develop interest in agriculture and then
Heather's working with and I bet mainly
Heather with Chris on a high tunnels
grant a federal funds formula grant
again tis to work in schools to
establish hi Tom gardens in elementary
schools to extend the growing season so
that students in elementary schools have
a greater window of opportunity to
garden and experiment with agriculture
right there on the school grounds and so
we've got a couple of schools where
we're building high tones this year and
then we'll add a couple each year after
that just as a glimpse I enjoy working
with undergraduates in research in an
education we kind of span different
majors and so this is just an example
a few students who we've worked with my
list graduated a couple years ago an
undergrad in aim how to add teachers
advise students for colleges and careers
primarily in the field of Agriculture
Aaron Smith started as in a similar way
as Marvin's daughter with the TST boces
system and we expanded her research
project here she was a undergrad in
human ecology but looking at high school
students perceptions of agriculture in
upstate New York and then Chris Smith is
currently a senior in agricultural
education and he's working with us on
the high tunnels grant looking at white
school administrators her teachers would
allow Chris to come in and build high
tunnels on a high tunnel on their
property why do they want to engage in
gardening or engage their students and
gardening and agriculture on the side so
that gives a little bit of an overview
of our research I've asked this team of
folks to share a little bit about our
teaching advising and our outreach
opportunities just to give you a flavor
of what we've been doing and then also
maybe that trigger some ideas for what
we could do and how we could build
collaborative potential moving into the
future so first I'll ask Jeff to share a
little bit about our teaching and
advising thank you def noon and Alex
urea the the distilled version Tom high
school for 17 years and it really like
the suggestion or idea about her
escaping landscaping as that was one of
my passion areas in teaching through
some graduate work at Virginia Tech I
was a landscaper to pay for graduate
school and was a Portland native was
boarding more info
stayed there about six months moved to
Jaden and then traveled new york state
of massachusetts and up through my
professional life and now back in Homer
area where I started off the process
then with Travis since the beginning of
semester work with your apartment for
three years of doing business planning
and across the state and all levels of
Agriculture as well but our safety
feature or the next one in terms of
agricultural science head students just
they actually just showing the trend
both for undergraduate and MIT students
and actually this credit after camp and
Travis first and also a real camp for
that growth in attracting students were
actually excited as we look forward and
positioning that I think that girls can
continue to increase and we're also
talking the interesting opportunities
when getting closer ties to Department
of Horticulture as I think there's a lot
of crossover and interests especially
working with the egg science folks it's
really good I was I Ashley was an Ag
education major simply because I had
interest areas and everything I said I
taught up until four years ago i was
using doctor dr. huskies notes from part
104 as some of my undergirding for plant
science classes that top but that's why
I enjoyed the AG education background is
it was diverse enough that that kept me
busy and I never very good generals my
specialist skills are still go
advising wise this is actually some are
from Summer Slide condensed into some
text we've got 36 education majors 3x
science we are the education minors is
continuing as a collaboration across of
the education group and departments
across university approximately 80
students there we're currently at six
MIT students one mps and one a student
again we've got it if that pipeline
kamagra folks in there and a strong
interest working towards the mtns
direction during graduate programs with
m-80s massroots of agricultural masters
in the art of teaching okay so basically
that's a master's program tip the
typical process is once you finish your
BS going to an MIT and that includes
student teaching and it's teaching
certification through that master's in
education i doing I'm supervising one
young lady who is student teaching as an
undergraduate but that's becoming rare
most folks will finish with the s and
I'm going to your student teaching as
the masters of our masters in there
we're also working with Leisha FFA
number 15 20 students in CLE Jeff a
doctor Park and I taxing my health
assisting that group in terms of my
unlike dr. Park I'm fairly know that the
fun part is that my passion is teaching
this this is what I get to do full
throttle I'm currently working with UT
some youth organizations class this
semester will roll into both yard of
teaching at program fighting next year
next fall semester with curriculum
instruction that youth organizations
popping back in strange spring about the
working with three student teachers this
semester in working through their
documentation process in the future if
we look forward we're working with X
ients and talking about some internship
possibilities in helping develop a
science internship and the horticulture
contribution is there's a lot of
interesting I used to I expect several
years as a coordinator for horticulture
contest state fair for 4h and FFA
working with marshaling achieve Lee a
little bit and I think there's a lot of
interesting potential for development I
also took dr. Prince's heaven for
leadership and life sciences class a
couple semesters go and there's some
really interesting opportunities for
collaboration is and that's so that's
the couplets kind of where we're at now
I actually think there's opportunities
for some of that too to engage and my a
little bit with that
so that yeah okay so right now there's
no I'm going to put motor and
agricultural education and does that let
me yeah let me clarify just a little bit
about where the the college's is at with
this slide in essence the college has
decided to continue the master of arts
in teaching as a graduate Major Wright a
graduate degree so students in any major
across the university thats related to
the sciences can earn a teaching
certificate in agriculture biology
chemistry physics or earth science so
there's what we focus on in agricultural
education is the agriculture piece and
also biology students can relatively
easily dual certified and obtain
weissinger in both agriculture and
biological sciences and then they're
certified to teach to the public schools
but then we've got colleagues in our
department who focus more on the physics
the chemistry and the earth science Pisa
so we encourage all of our students as
agriculture students to duel certify a
good buyer so that graduate degree will
continue some of those students that we
advise you are primarily agricultural
education students will follow us and
somehow you know they'll be Horticulture
Department students plant science
reporter graduates is that what is it ok
yeah plant sciences okay then yeah
they'll be with all of that yeah ok so
yeah but in students were clear yeah
that's sort of what were you
yes these students are currently
enrolled in the University of the
University says okay any undergraduate
agate student you can continue and earn
a degree in Ag education Tony and the
folks and agro sciences we've been
working with them and honestly the
decision are thinking at how do we go to
crop in soils horticulture how do we
navigate that because we got I think
good relationships with good
relationships coming here we have a good
person Tony and Tony said everybody the
students here one of these
undergraduates if they want to switch
over to the average science major
somehow that's fine we can do it but if
they want to continue and graduate as
against students they can but these
students will follow their my advising
load right now you know Jeff and I are
splitting those responsible is up so
those undergrads will come to this
department right really did the
education rider across the university
the Arts and Sciences College other the
other individual departments even in
engineering value having an
undergraduate education minor so that's
not going to go away the classes we
teach contribute to that minor that
minor administrative Lee won't be housed
here to my knowledge that's still up in
the air but that that won't I don't
think be here but then so really will
bring some majors any new address
education undergrad it won't know what
can apply as an undergrad to AG
education beginning this current year
students who want to certify to teach
will be funneled into the agro science
major in that educate
and communications concentration and
then Jeff and I are working closely with
Tony and five tiny ways to make sure
that they can complete the coursework
they need to get ready for teacher
certification and so we lose our
academic program in this process as an
undergraduate major but we supplant that
with the Accra science major and
contributing help the mass due to major
in plant sciences let's say let's say
some are online i want to teach well
continued and graduate with a plant
sciences major in the holder to the m82
certify probably in biology and
agricultural sciences okay the one thing
that we have to we would ask y'all
tolerate us a bit on to prepare to teach
high school agriculture students need to
know about the breadth of agriculture so
they complete courses and pretty much
all about six majors they have an animal
science and aim natural resources to an
agronomy type course and then a
horticulture type of course we have a
same build in in international course
and then two other Cal selective so
that's a breadth of course work and then
in the past then they create a complete
specialization in other words that's
kind of what we do in the hacker science
major students have a breadth of act
coursework and then concentrated so some
of our students will be agriscience
measures that will advise you'll take an
animal science kind of course hopefully
that's tolerable in a plant science so
these students will falls on the
collegiate FFA that to whatever that's
where that'll active not just an Ag
education club that's a we have students
from all majors across the college
that'll be asked here where you can work
with
Tony of bed and it's in my mind how do
we do we need a tango science club in a
collegiate FFA maybe there's some
murdering of efforts there as well yeah
it's that make sense it's kind of it's
going to be a little bit of awkwardness
good we'll continue this teacher
certification program and we're going to
but the actor science major is
multidisciplinary so will those will be
our main undergrad advisees but you know
where appropriate we can help out other
places so Travis that number of 36 is
not going to grow because you're not
accepting any new students now this
number won't grow this number would be
where we would see growth get all the
open you under graduates that are
interested in Ag education are going to
be funneled through the agricultural
sciences major this is what the
administration on it however as those
students are flag they'll be going to
Travis so Travis in this group are going
to be advising I eat their di yet kids
and so Travis will have the
responsibility of that it's the only way
they couldn't have that major up there
anymore since it's right but so right
that number 236 is going to be the
quantity if we're going to see the
increase its going to be within the AG
science education concentration of
concentration of students that would
typically be advised by Travis in this
room so that hopefully will increase
yeah well and we'll see these students
you know many of our courses we hope in
any case
okay the other piece that I don't know
that educ course prefix the
administration has said will continue so
these currently are educ prefixed
courses but that teaching load I think
gets credited to whatever wherever the
department's back to these happens right
so you know these courses are primarily
for education majors but through this
reorganization Jeff and I are working to
create a system where we can broadly
offering beyond o youth organizations
really tailors towards having to work
with students in FFA and 4-h they know
out there's some a lot of students on
campus who already currently work with
Boy Scouts or Girl Scouts or church
youth groups or other youth populations
and the ideas that you would have been
working with 4-h and FFA from a youth
development perspective are the same
across those organizations so who Jeff
and I really challenged to think okay
how can we stretching the course where
we have kind of a maybe a general
lecture on Monday or Tuesday rather and
then some specific breakouts sections
later in the week so these courses
generally they have a potential probably
30 or 40 students the art of teaching is
a fairly large course it's been capped
we haven't taught this before we're
going to be teaching it for one semester
with it has been capped at about 125
students a semester and once we take the
cap off it Kimbrough curriculum
instruction has been primarily a
graduate level curriculum instruction
how do you put together syllabus or
subjective is that kind of thing course
it attracts about 30 students thence to
teaching is our internship for the m80
and it's a 15 credit hour and ever per
student and we'll have like next year
eight students that will visit three
times each semester out of the field
whether where they're teaching in those
schools and we know whatever the part we
and where we go we have to create space
and we have created space in our
teaching allotment to think about ways
that we can teach a course that
contributes to the department and so
that's open for some discussion as
people say wow horticulture would be
great if we had a course that would help
some of our students think about this he
said hi we have some expertise in that
let's do that it could help some are a
lot of students ism so there's space
there because we we don't want to be
this step child that's just been kind of
quasi adopted by the department we
really want fine be integrated as much
as your life anyway our outreach
programs we're working with primarily
youth but the sis's and saints have a
basic awareness appreciation
understanding of Agriculture we call our
outreach program agricultural outreach
and education we're funded I think even
this year by the Department of Ag and
markets at the tune of summer
neighborhood of 335 thousand dollars a
year the three programs we mentioned our
language classroom working with the AG
teachers throughout the state FFA and
then I'm the faculties
I mentioned earlier in the TST boces new
mission agricultural and environmental
sciences program which is housed up at
viewer and labs actually the basement of
gutermann labs but they work with
faculty those students there's about 12
and 15 year who are at the upper end
academically in their high schools they
have to apply the exceptions in the
program and then they as part of their
curriculum here they work with faculty
throughout the university primarily the
college of management on research
projects for this year and I was just up
there this morning of the 12 students in
Michelle's current class they introduce
themselves and five applied early
decision are coming here to Cornell
there were a couple that are not coming
attending for element number five we're
waiting on decisions that we out later
this week so it's a nice feeder into
some for some good students in the
corner so I'll turn it over to Julia to
explain the youth development program
ffuck hello I'll stand to the side
because I'm quite vertically challenged
with here in senescent any miracle grow
in my how many people you are familiar
with with the FSA part of it or know
what it is okay there's some there's
actually it's a pretty good percentage
for those of you don't know what it is
very excited to tell you about it
because I'm quite sure the ones you know
what it is to be very excited about how
horticulture relates to it because it's
a really easy way that connects students
high school students with communities
with schools and really get strong
agricultural
doubt there so I'm Julia Julia talansky
i am the youth program specialist for
cornell specifically i work as the New
York State FFA executive secretary so I
work with these four thousand students
and with their teachers to help them
have agricultural opportunities and
leadership opportunities that will
develop them into the most outstanding
young people that could go and transform
the faces of their communities and of
American agriculture so lofty goal we do
whatever you are doing you say for 4000
yes there's 4,000 students now when
we're trying to grow that number I
thought that I cannot of opportunity for
growth but we're located within public
schools and private schools about 4,000
of them on a high school level for this
year what up there is and for those of
you who've heard of it for myself
familiar it makes a positive difference
in the lives of students by solving
their potential for premier leadership
personal growth and career success
through agricultural education and
that's a kicker it has to be developed
through an agricultural education
program so what happens it does is for
these four thousand students in about
eighty five chapters across new york
state each year so that's 85 schools in
85 communities in new york it exposes
them to agricultural information and her
cultural opportunities and it engages
them in a way that makes them excited
about what they can do as a career and
hopefully it turns them on to an
agricultural career and if it doesn't
hopefully it turns them into a really
informed consumer who's out there
advocating for rural rural agriculture
and agricultural in urban areas just a
lot of things that turns a min
one who is pro agriculture was that
horticulture or animal AG or natural
resources it gives them a an informed
standing where they can begin as a
community member so they does this
through three main things these are my
kids so you can enjoy them just as much
as I do we do three things career
development events we have supervised
agricultural experiences and then we are
really heavy on the leadership
development and student in patients so
career development events last year we
had 148 competitive forums and 3 p-8
agricultural career areas there are over
2,000 students that participated in
these last year and these are very
diverse they range from things like
dairy cattle showmanship to public
speaking a lot of them are housed
directly in areas that are plant and
horticultural based in fact we actually
have a horticulture career development
event there's a flora culture that
there's a landscaping opportunity so
there's a lot of things that these
students do and what a CBE is a weird
above an event is it's a competitive
opportunity for a student in in a
real-world setting for them to
experience and find personal success and
once a student has opportunity to feel
personally successful I'm sure you know
that's when they realize this is what
I'm passionate about this is what I want
to do this is what I want to study in
college and go on for a career and
because there's so many different career
development areas we really have a
chance to feed students into all areas
of the agricultural sector a lot of
those students find success there and
end up developing a supervised
experience and going on to college in
that area so we're really proud of those
cds that we offer the next thing we
supervised agricultural experiences they
are an individualized projects that a
student
Phillips and all students are encouraged
to have them and we try to help them to
get them started because I'm sure as you
know not all students who are
agricultural II interested are coming
from a farming background we're coming
from mom and dad all in all greenhouse
they just become interested in it how do
we get them to be able to be successful
while we recognize them with a lot of
awards in fact last year we had six
students who were finalists on a
national level for what their
agricultural product project was one of
them was a flora culture girl we give
them degrees and recognize them for
their continued work in an area which
encourages them to keep people on in
their field and to record hours to learn
competencies to learn how to describe
what it is they do that's exceptional we
even offer grants to help students
startup projects so sometimes they might
be getting a grant for to help them by
their first cap or they might be giving
a grant to be able to purchase some land
or purchase some plugs so that they can
start a greenhouse I had a student last
year who with a proficiency winner who
had her own high title and what she did
was she had this own it was like Amy's
high tunnel and she sold all her own
plants and had her own agribusiness it
all started because she was able to get
interested in her project through for AG
program so we have 4,000 students each
of them have access to these things the
final thing that we do leadership
development a lot of students join FFA
or agricultural education because in
their schools they don't have access to
something that really makes them feel
valuable personally successful and FFA
provides that opportunity for students
every year year round we offer at least
hours as leadership development and
personal growth for high school students
from New York whether it's a student
class the opportunity to serve as a
state-level officer and travels around
look this month so that a lot of time in
Albany with students speaking to the
Senate AG committee that's explained to
them what agricultural education is in
their schools gives them a chance to
speak with a senator one-on-one it's a
17-year old student who walks up and is
not afraid to talk to their
representative or we have 300 student
leadership conference 300 student
leadership conferences in Syracuse New
York where the students can come
together get caught on fire for what
they can do setting goals vision
teamwork those things in ignite a
community of United school we provide
that to our students it gets the
students engaged in agricultural
education and starts them on a path to
success after all surely so that's what
I can say is in a nutshell I can talk
for a long time about it cuz I believe
in it and I'm a product of it but unless
there are any questions I'm going to let
you guys hear about some of the other
excellent things that we do in
identification yeah talk about there's
room for expansion how are you trying to
say that that thing into places that are
absolutely that's a really good question
and the answer is that a lot of people
don't understand that what they do in
their classrooms is already
agriculturally related we're going down
to New York City next week to meet with
several schools that have agricultural
classes that don't understand that their
agriculture sherry was on the felt this
morning with someone and trying to say
hey can we come visit you we'd love to
talk to you about getting involved with
FFA and agricultural education so we
don't have agriculture we only have a
greenhouse so but that's that's a big
perceptions people don't understand
there's agriculture in their schools
they don't understand I visited schools
that have animals and they do exotic
animals as part of what they do they
don't understand thats related to
agriculture so that's one way another
way is by helping to keep more to be
able to have more students in those
schools have access to agricultural
education within the school so getting a
stronger presence and we've worked with
the rural school the role school
association to have our students in
front of those administrators so they
realize just how high quality those
active members are and recognize we want
all of our students have access to this
so it's a lofty goal but I really think
that it's one that's quite attainable
especially if we partner with groups
like yours that has access to teachers
and schools that maybe we've never been
able to partner with before any other
questions all right I'll bring up my my
sort of other half like I said a third
my name is heather davis i'm the
coordinator for the new york adding the
classroom program
you've heard of AG in the classroom I
just wanted me to work with Martine
schiele over here especially on our
control group programs so I'm very
excited about this partnership and the
possibility that it presents just a
brief introduction about me on consider
in agriculture literacy specialist like
this definitely fancy title but I call
myself just the coordinator for the air
guy in the classroom I'm approaching
three years as the coordinator I came on
board right after I finished my masters
in agriculture and biology education
insurance was my advisor and I've got my
BS endearing management the University
of New Hampshire Massachusetts New
Hampshire girl so the eastern eastern
region rep for the National I'm in the
classroom program for those of you who
don't know what a confessor is a
nationally recognized program we are
housing nefa the USDA pretty much every
state does have an ad in the classroom
programs of kind of tellin Farm Bureau
something
tell in their land grant University so
there's there's a few of us that are in
the lien greens we consider ourselves
career but but we love it here so I also
plan to start my PhD in the fog still
working on the access code map and I'm
excited to begin nap oops sherry and
Vincent eff jump up the meter Ganga
classroom program our main mission is to
foster and awareness appreciation and
understanding of the food and fiber
system pretty much and everyone we are
kind of for those kids that may not be
in an agricultural program or not from a
farm and that we really just want to
give them the understanding of what
agriculture is so they can make educated
decision that citizens as consumers we
really reach out Kate through 101 we
like to think of our group as kind of
reaching every every component of a
society and being able to educate
everyone on that primarily we can look
at K through 12 and our programs pre-k
through 12 specifically and we really
approach it through teachers we develop
programs and resources
utilize in their classrooms we conduct
workshops in their classrooms and really
are trying to strengthening their their
communication best that we can again
produce materials for them to actually
utilize and it perhaps it would be
helpful our partners are obviously
Cornell I'm a hope so since you're here
new york state education department New
York Farm Bureau and the New York State
Department of Ag and markets so we have
a lot of partners out there as well as
CC we really really rely on them for
some of our larger programs are really
strong teachers that continue to come
back and utilize our resources so it
really try to strengthen those
partnerships throughout the state some
of our major programs we just wrapped up
our agricultural literacy week we run
that during national athlete although
they switched it on us so we are we
behind and they did inform you that kind
of outfit but this is probably our
larger program we reach about 35,000
students 35 to 40 thousand students each
year we decide upon a book that we're
going to talk about and usually we
decide the theme before that so this
year we were discussing the poultry
industry but in the past we've done
maple we've done vegetable gardening
timber industry was last year when Gary
as well so this was our sixth year and
what happens is we choose 40
usually cooperative extension or Farm
Bureau members in every county of New
York State believe this year we only
have 58 counties but they kind of get
lumped in down there in the city and
they'll fill coordinate the local
efforts and we provide the books to them
we've donated over 1,400 books this year
and then volunteers go in and read to
the students about that particular theme
talk about the importance of Agriculture
and then conduct an activity thats
related to the book so we're still
getting our feedback from this year it
seems to have been really successful
year had lots of pictures of people with
chickens or people dressed up as
chickens or people it's kinda crazy we
definitely had some honey bees when
you're diving bell vegetable production
and horticulture so there's a lot of
kind of free range with what we want to
discuss and there's some great books out
there so that's a
link that we could use for the
Horticulture Department our kids growing
food programming is our big huge aura as
I said I where up with martini glee
we're hopefully going to develop
concerns the internship utilizing a
horticulture student that would let to
work with schools and work with garden
based education and do some of the
legwork and meeting with school gardens
and also reporting as far as our gardens
go the kids mark food program is a
five-hundred-dollar mini grant program
it started in 1998 we have over 350
school gardens throughout New York State
quite a few urban gardens down in New
York City we will fund anything from a
non-existent garden to an already
existing wiring that just needs a little
extra TLC so we have a lot of hydropower
hydroponic gardens classic gardens in
you back school yard as well as grow
labs and that type of things we're
really interested in funding anything
that's going to get students connected
with agriculture horticulture and
understanding where their food comes
from after they know people program I
came through 12 curriculum that
highlights agriculture in every sense of
the word we do free workshops for
educators throughout the state and we'll
do a six hour workshop and try to
integrate all the aspects of AG in the
classroom and an Ag education into that
workshop while
the curriculum is a great resource for
teachers it's all set to new york state
standards so they can basically take it
and go and not have to worry about how
do i integrate this into my per coulomb
either one is helping faster and we
really trying to make those connections
for them and show them that it's easy to
incorporate agriculture concepts into
their already existing and very heavy
classwork advent a certain teacher here
every year we highlight teacher
throughout New York state that has taken
agricultural concepts integrated them
into their classroom busy our teachers
from brooklyn's she has created a
basically an agricultural oasis in her
Brooklyn school she has transformed
their school yard from concrete to a
beautiful garden they do the fresh
fruits and vegetable program every day
she's got school and her classroom
ambassadors that bring presents to her
all the classes in her school so the
kids can have a nutrition and healthy
snack and she really utilizes
agricultural concepts of everything that
she does and has really welcomed her
whole school into that program so we're
very excited to be to be celebrating all
the work that she does and we welcome k
through 12 teachers that are integrating
those concepts to apply for this every
year I Love New York agriculture contest
of contest that we run every year it's
very easy it's set all the concepts are
the key components to it are set to New
York State Standards so teachers don't
have to take a lot of the time saying
why this is going to help students reach
their standards each K through 6 pre-k
through six each grade level has a
different component that their specific
fulfills so freaking pre-kindergarten
basically driving favorite farm animal
but we also have 6th grade they made
product Maps or product posters of their
favorite New York State commodity or
their favorite New York State product
and they create this beautiful poster
discussing why it's their favorite and
how many are contributes to the growth
of that commodity and then our New York
I whole class remotes that we really try
to use it just as a boarding house for
all components of agriculture education-
may miss you guys finally they talk two
switches but they don't know where to
start they don't know where to find
anything so we really try to pull
everything together they get concise and
easy for them to use so they can come to
AG in the classroom and say I'm looking
for something on how roughly and they
can find something on there it may be a
link to the national AG in the classroom
page that will then get them
to plan but at least they've got that
first step in the door be able discuss
where those products come from where
they can get the resources so talk
really fast oh there are there any
questions good afternoon everybody awake
engineer over there maybe they can hear
us no you get away from responsible so
was that my name is sherry lighthall
I've actually been with the education
outreach project for almost 14 years I
taught one year of high school
agriculture harvest on an environment to
get the debate I want to keep your check
I talked one year before I joined the
project at that time we thought it would
be a one year grant through the
Department of Ag markets and excited to
say that 14-minute were still going
strong as you can see I did go to
Cornell University for medical graduate
actually in natural resources management
originally and it took one class in
horticulture and it was the same one
that Jeff mentioned
same time with dr. Kowalewski and from
that experience and learned that you
know even someone from an urban area
down in southern New York could actually
grow plants from that experience it led
me to believe that maybe I want to be a
teacher and allow others to learn from
my experiences how they can grow plants
so when we talk about leveraging between
our department and education it's a
great opportunity for us to have other
folks who want to learn about not only
the horticultural plant sciences but
then take that to another level and
teach it to our secondary students many
of our programs across the state teach a
diverse area of disciplines and AG
education but quite a few of those
teachers they're only experiences in
horticulture and they want to go out and
they want to teach plant sciences so
it's it's very crucial that we always
have an opportunity for those folks to
learn the skill they need then take that
to the classroom for me as a student it
was the way that I was able to get into
the classroom I was very confident when
it came to making a paper doll test book
you know because I learned that through
my horticultural experience the other
disciplines you have to learn as well
and horticulture definitely his area
that Jeff and I were talking and we
think that there's probably a ninety
percent of our programs across the state
include one component of horticulture or
plant science in their add classes right
now so again a little bit more about
myself I also have two children Emily
and Hanna one is cold flu right now
hopefully your father's watching her and
that I have
a gardener as well and I am unique to
the Agra debris to project and that I am
not on campus when the program was
initially started in nineteen ninety-six
the outreach staff were not housed in
the department they actually will field
staff since that time I'm the only one
who's still in the field everyone else
has joined Travis in the department so I
don't come to ithaca very often my
office is actually three hours north of
here in the other objects real quickly
we want to leave some time for questions
I want to give you just a few moments
about what I do I'm basically a support
staff for all of our secondary
agriculture programs whether they need
help with their curriculum whether they
help with learning about specific
disciplines that they can teach their
students or if it's just helping them
understand the opportunities that they
have for their own professional
development growth year round we offer
professional development and growth
opportunities for teachers and all
subject areas from environmental science
plant science hydroponics mechanical
science animal science and those are
through workshops that we do throughout
the year on the site also times we bring
them together real quick i'll highlight
in june we do our largest professional
development for teachers and we look for
experts from the field we've had quite a
few faculty from your department has
helped us throughout the years this fall
we did a workshop for
and hydroponics at some of your staff
health as well those teachers come
together for three days they receive
resources and materials for their
classroom as well as the opportunity
collaborate with one another just to
learn to grow and learn about they too
can be better educators currently we
serve over 250 teachers in everywhere
from Long Island to Buffalo those
numbers continue to grow as Julia
mentioned every day just this morning I
had a call from a school in Brooklyn
it's called the high school for science
and technology and they informed us that
they also have a greenhouse they just
put in in the fall they have 987
students k through 12 all take a class
in plant science they didn't know that
support existed for them and once again
we found another program in an urban
setting who is growing food for their
community they're actually selling that
food to d'agastino markets in the area
so that was a little bit about what we
do I don't want to take time for
questions so I'm going to have Travis
come back up here if there's anything
that we can do to answer additional
questions I know we have some pamphlets
in the back also a lot some of the
offerings of our programs
just quickly this is example and the
slides of other organizations that we
belong to the AG education the teachers
have an association there's a new york
agate Leadership Council that provides
direction for our programs but 4-h folks
sit on that council as well as the deans
of the schools of Agriculture at all the
Sunni institutions including here at
Cornell that's kind of coordinated
through our work I served on the cow
social sciences honor committee
undergraduate honors committee I
mentioned s cotton act as the North
American colleges and teachers of
agriculture and then the last three are
again organizations last is the
Association for leadership education
which is kind of an ad based leadership
development professional organization
just give you some impacts on Cal's of
the group effort here Kallis has had an
interest in increasing the students who
have act experiences in their background
4-h FFA and farm experiences this is a
slide that and lafave and I put together
for an APA lu conference this summer and
you can see this the number of students
do with for FFA in their background who
applied the Cornell who are offered
admissions than who ultimately
matriculated doesn't seem like wild
kinds of numbers 14 to the growth of 38
but we admit as a college about 600
undergrads a year so if all the students
who we offered admissions to attended
Cornell without the faith background
you'd have something like approaching 10
40 students and a nice growth some more
students with agricultural background
check sir niko vector give up why aren't
we yield in that number but what do you
think that's about because he doesn't
act at all change when you come to work
these are students across all majors in
the columns and yeah it could be that
they don't this is all majors across the
whole university that's not just add yet
students write these students go
foodscience Natural Resources
horticultural crops and soils animal
science that's a great question because
the yield we've talked about this is a
department wire now is what we get we
admit these kids in that path well 40-60
pretty good percentage don't come yeah
that's kind of the next we've worked
we've implemented several programs the
anger science major is help increase
these numbers of applicants but yeah to
me that interesting question is what do
we do about this gap here why are we
losing 20 students who were offered
admissions torn elbow don't don't intend
here some you know this anecdotally 3fk
there's some that we know from New York
City who are admitted that while this is
just a whole universe away from what
they know where they attended university
somewhere closer it's a good question I
don't have a good answer but that's the
kind these are the kinds of questions
that as I move forward and researched it
would be a huge project all but that's
an interesting question why are we not
filled with students to a fantastic
agricultural university at the same time
as it shows we haven't through the
admissions office watered down the
criteria to admit students these are
their SATs scores over the same time
period and if you know about s18 scores
100 points of the standard deviation so
we increase s80 scores with those same
students by over one standard deviation
which is pretty healthy what I don't
know I haven't compared is the whole
colleges change in SATs
more high quality students from
agricultural backgrounds these are civil
activist that we've thought about in
migrating to the Horticulture Department
ongoing research like we have price
stepped up with high tunnels the guard
based learning program the beginning
farmer program as Sharon mentioned a lot
of our high school teachers do have a
green houses on site so how can we help
our students learn to manage those green
houses both for production but also for
experimentation to give students high
quality educational experiences Marsha
and several of us have recognized the
need for some informal learning methods
kinds of maybe it's a course in informal
learning methods for undergrads and or
grad students at the University we're
working with Tony in the multi desire
anger science major with the internship
and then also a capstone course want to
continue to graduate level truth of
instruction course a couple of your
faculty mentioned that you'll have a lab
that is a teaching lab and maybe
collaboratively we can find someplace to
maybe have some renovation and use that
more effectively to more number more
students and as you can see through the
discussions of their outreach programs
we're interested in youth leadership
development and the college says we
developed leaders across the college but
I there's a few courses around that
maybe we could enhance that throughout
the university there through the college
rules why horticulture I had discussions
with lead to other department chairs and
they were gracious that were wonderful
had several discussion with other
faculties this is sort of one of those
awkward dating kinds of jobs Urdu
greenup shuel arrangement but the end of
the day horticulture has
certainly in yield and agricultural
production but also the influence of
people in that equation and that creates
some in my mind some intellectual space
for educating people about agriculture
we felt an observed to focus on teaching
and interested leadership which matches
some of our interests that we already
have some common outreach activities
going on seems to be a mutual interest
in engagement of the public with
agricultural endeavors and special youth
and then we're excited our agriculture
teachers really straddle the fence
between being class they are classroom
teachers that are students but they also
need to be agricultural professionals
which contribute to the agricultural
industry and so being in a disciplinary
unit like horticulture I think offers us
opportunities to enhance our students
knowledge about different facets of
Agriculture so with that we're thinking
beyond time and I apologize for that any
questions that we can answer what was
getting for video up okay if you all
didn't move fast enough doesn't appear
to be okay okay i trust those that maybe
you get those get self-identify when
they fly they do so within a block
identify they identify on their
application and then just thing I don't
know how much faculty know but as you
were it's great thing Dean Henry
instituted a fee waiver of the
application fee to point out for
students with poor age FFA or farm
backwards and we publicized that through
the agonal classroom network and the FFA
Network CES has to extend but you know I
don't think they broadcast that widely
but you know just
it's a seventy dollar waiver but just
eliminating that barrier we there's more
students who have applied here to
Cornell is because we've removed that
one simple barrier of seventy bucks and
yet some kids will take a chance on
cornell mawson while they are admissible
here in Sioux see also we exhibit at the
National FFA convention in Indianapolis
in October which draws 50,000 high
school students and lots of universities
give out trinkets and pennants and pins
we give out the fee waivers to those
interesting me about the Prasad yes
we've got the students around the
University who are here from out of
state who came just because I they heard
it from Alvarez great University
explored with us a little bit made it
free to apply there do we break here and
then stars of the University so that's I
think one of the ways we're valuable
with local colleges and network and I
hear through my associations with the
USDA ESCA identifying and helping to
nurture youth interested in agricultural
studies and agricultural sciences and
the programs we have our direct conduit
one not the only but a nice confidence
of those students and so be able to
leverage those pretentious morning
person that's a common
interactions oftentimes happen in the
corners
great that you guys come to leverage
somehow administration provided the
space in the building or both by rather
than stuck over in all or we go normally
like that that's one of the negation of
man right out I had to pick up the
essence you know tinny your faculty
meeting the other day was wonderful and
yeah I bet you all said World Food Prize
what this feels nice you know and then
the group of the younger faculties of
croissant sure you were invited or not
invited but younger family I'm at last
week fruit coffee and that was a
refreshing conversation I've asked
Marvin I haven't fallen up yet if I
could meet just informally with her some
of us grab coffee with y'all as
scheduled to fly over the next couple of
weeks unless of course it's an end of
this presentation boy that's not with
anything from the market if you'll let
me know of that houses or do you want
coffee we have ovulated miss bala pick
up what other things and it came up a
couple times we have a big extension
commitment in this department I saw you
use word outreach and so will be
threaded I try to try to figure out with
it makes me there was some effort with
extensions
in the classroom ER so there's an
integration error how much do you guys
sort of could we have students that want
to go out and work in Cooperative
Extension are you offer anything further
for those sort of that might go on into
adult education or even they exclusive
some of us old dogs that might need some
new tricks in adult education that's one
area of the end of the 40 or so students
that we have enrolled in the
undergraduate programs about the third
of those are interested in Cooperative
Extension as a career track problem
cooperative and or not not a school they
want educate about agriculture but don't
like the idea of a school setting so
there's an interest there what we do in
our program planning course and the
youth organizations course we touch on
extension but from my perspective that's
an area where there's a need and the
college to offer additional coursework
to help out when Appleby has taught a
course in enix extension agricultural
education but of course lens in a phased
retirement this might be his last
semester actually teaching that course
and so I've been talking with he and
Paul O'Connor about how to continue that
course because it also counts for the
actor science major so that we want to
do that where I think we can contribute
and yeah just go Mia we could help do it
yeah yeah it could be sort of the people
yeah and that's the neat part about what
we've done in the education Bart really
a focused in a lot of ways on very
formal school education that we're
faculty in adult education but had
limited engagement with extension so
Chris
another related Frank rounded up
international graduate students come
oftentimes with a very jaded view or
help you with all of our expansion and
those international students really need
experience how it could be done in how
positive so from the standpoint of
exploring you know here are the
different systems internationally
which ones work which one stone which
has been trying to discard it that's
another aspect was really very important
and these are the kinds of opportunities
that I think we could explore some we
have some expertise others Westers I
think we need to finish off lost would
you even have some coffee up there next
week so I am talented meeting over the
faculty in Geneva well close up now with
a very great thanks to the wonderful
presentation you sent in like the term
team but I think there's a whole unit
right Robert lover Travis add the unit
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu